my first guest sitting right here to my
right does that all the time he's one of
my favorite people on the planet I'm
thrilled to call him a great friend and
a longtime colleague he will be part of
NFL Network's coverage of Super Bowl 50
for once it's all over if somebody balls
they will get the call on NFL gameday
prime he's also here on behalf of
restore hair and restore hair I know you
just did to restore hair plug yes but
that did shave several to eight years of
you just with the wig yeah he did it he
looked great project you guys are killer
to shave game right now you know what
yes okay all right here we go it's a
Caruso one you're with Deion Sanders
okay prime how you been what's going on
getting great man
I'm feeling good I'm healthy I'm looking
good of course you are everything has
been great what do you what do you think
of when you think of the Super Bowl what
comes to mind for you I think of the
biggest sporting event in the world this
is it we got it
MLB cane touches NBA definitely came
touches with it we got one shot this is
it you don't get multiple chances of
this one you get one shot there's no
four out of seven eight no best of seven
that's my man
so what about you on Super Sunday what
are your memories of your Super Sunday
um especially in Miami that's right on
great memories the best thing I can
remember a couple things yes I can
remember that got the team getting all
flustered and several people tell this
story rich and they get it wrong okay
it's like they was all flustered it was
on a Wednesday a lot of the young guys
missed curfew so some of the older guys
got up and blasted young guys and I
couldn't take it no more so I finally
got up and say hey hey we gonna beat the
breaks off San Diego what we trippin for
come on say that Wednesday we're at the
crib on winds ain't nobody got no curfew
let's just forget this man let them
apologize let's go do what we do in the
rest is history
what did the coaching staff say to you
to you when you said that you nothing
they wouldn't in the room it was the
players only meeting okay right and then
when you hear the story from other
people
they were like Jerry and I was face to
face if we're about to fight that never
happened I'm not gonna be face to face
with anybody because it's gonna get like
that I'm swinging first anyway so it was
never that way right
but that was the truth trueness of the
story so just again young players went
out broke curfew yeah you said no
players only meeting I got this thing
what do we what are we then the story
got out that I was one of the guys late
I was not I was never late to anything
you know I am but I know you are I'm
never late to anything you are one of
the greatest professionals I've ever
thank you that is a true story I mean
you always come buttoned up you're on I
mean sitting here saying on time I mean
you really you said you always mindful
of others I will never forget and I will
say this when we started working
together the first time me you and
Mariucci used to do the gameday
highlights you know good old days was me
you and mooch the Moochie man and I
remember Steve had not done television
before Steve showed up his first Super
Bowl his first thing he did for NFL
Network he was at Super Bowl 40 in
Detroit he had just been fired in
Detroit it was very difficult for him to
come out in Detroit and be out and be
part of the paparazzi then the next year
he was with us full-time and the three
of us were doing their shows together
and mooch remarkably certainly since we
just saw him two weeks ago on game day
morning shotgunning syrup on live
television and Frank Caliendo is gonna
do a great Mariucci imitation in our
number three well he what he was
reserved like he didn't say very much he
was trying to find his way and what do I
say how do I say it you had done
television obviously for CBS and then
went back to play and now you were then
I fell Network I had done Sports Center
in a ton of television and they put they
put you in the
yeah okay and Steve on the end and you
pull the producers around and say no no
if I'm in the middle and I'm talking to
rich and I'm doing what I need to do
mooch I'll just be sitting on the end
doing nothing it'll be lost and we
swapped it out we swapped and you were
on the end for the entire time and you
were you were the one you were mindful
of that as opposed to well primes gonna
show up and of course you're gonna be in
the middle and of course you're not
gonna care what other people say the guy
in the middle was the guy right right
well I mean yes that's right there in
the middle and they like let's put Dion
in the middle and you're like no no put
me on the side mooch ill get lost let's
do this all three of us together I will
never forget that I appreciate it no
absolutely recorded story I appreciate
and that's an applause line by the way
that's the applause line here another
Jeb Bush moment here in Florida saying
please clap but so at any rate so you
said there was one other thing that you
said that you think of about your game
day I had a Lamborghini delivered to me
[Laughter]
we had practice and I was talking to the
Lamborghini dealership I said I want you
to take it to this hotel leave the door
open and leave it just like that I got
it from there
so we're pulling up to the hotel after
practice and everybody's like oh my god
is a black bikini Diablo right in front
of hotel I want two cars this and Eric
Davis said y'all know darn well who's
the only fool to do something like that
that's what I recall what color was it a
black of course and then you did in fact
beat the brakes off in San Diego like we
knew we would you knew you would yep so
the Superbowl tech technically that year
was the NFC Championship game yes that
was the Super Bowl do you know I was
there as a local reporter no I was there
that day yeah it 4k RCR TV with my
equipment you and it's amazing how life
works I was there covering it you were
covering Michael Irvin that day and the
great day
Mike had a great game Mike had a great
game I mean I think he has a playoff
record right yeah and there's still an
argument over pass interference words
into the game we settled that earlier on
another show - which other show where
your son skip and chin okay and how did
that work
we had to demonstrate what really
transpired and I told Mike he got to let
it go it's about 25 years ago let it go
man right yeah I let it go it's over I
can't have your wife rolling up on me
saying you know your special appearance
with my man no no Michael Irvin 12
catches 192 yards yes now let's prep is
that when we played man I went to Mike
when we played zone we double we doubled
Mike and I went to Harper another side
so I just want to make you you can't get
rid of that land like that and not
explain there's a nuance beyond Sanders
here on the Rich Eisen show we had
Richard Sherman on last week I
essentially said to him what's going on
with you and Revis and I know last night
you were at the media night last night
and you you you go but it doesn't seem
like he's the one who's letting anything
go like whose name is in whose mouth to
start this thing here this is what I
thought
I thought Revis shut it germ yes and I
told sure this is your week
this is your year let it go do not
respond and he told me I reached him too
late he said I understand I love you
appreciate you but you got to me too
late so he didn't respond no I I just
found out that Sherm started it years
ago this dates back four or five years
ago when Rivas came back after injury
right and I don't I don't know if he was
performing up to par and Sherm
supposedly said something about him well
I knew there had to be something yeah
but I mean years later it's Sherm now in
this run by the way interception in the
divisional game interception in the NFC
Championship really he can go three in a
row as a matter of fact
the last player over the age of 31 to do
what he's done is at read and we all
know what his credentials are yes so the
question is is why why now like why what
what and I turn to you my cornerback
don't like my son I love them I
appreciate them both of them are
certainly future hall-of-famers we just
got to let that kind of nonsense go and
and we shouldn't be fighting each other
if we're gonna argue about anything
let's listen let's go into the receivers
let's not go at one another let's talk
about the receivers so unfortunately
that took place but they're mature guys
and I'm sure that when they look back on
and reflect back on it's nonsense Deion
Sanders here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about it then how do you see
fit of Super Bowl 50 for man breaking
down this is one of the best matchups
that we've had in quite some time
offensively defensively special teams
personnel I love both quarterbacks we're
praying that Garoppolo if he has to
throw the ball 20 to 30 times can't be
that guy right we're praying that San
Francisco's defense can hold up against
that speed we're praying that San
Francisco can run the ball effectively
but if they don't what's going to
transpire I cannot wait to see how it
plays out both teams are evenly matched
man this is gonna be a really good game
we could sit here for another three
hours in every scenario that we game out
is a feasibility I mean every single
thing it's not out of the realm of
possibility for something to happen but
if you had to choose because you're not
part of the pregame show part of
thriller anymore thriller like you know
long that video was how long yeah I
couldn't wait to do that one yeah we'll
miss you I don't I don't think Kansas
City you could get off to a slow start
like they have in the previous two games
against this team and make a comeback
right so they can't get down right it's
gonna be a good one I'm not gonna
predict anything right now okay I want
good football I want a good
Super Bowl it's gonna go down to the
wire that's an applause line right there
and the few minutes I have left with you
you're one of the only people I can ask
this what advice would you give JJ Watt
for going on Saturday Night Live this
weekend
what advice he's going on this week yeah
he's hosting Saturday night what do you
think you hosted back yes I did be
yourself right okay now now this is what
could get you Saturday Night Live
okay you got everybody coming up to you
like they really admire you they really
respect you like what you do is being
I've been following your career and then
a picture that skit then this guy comes
up to my britches get you just get
everybody pictures you the skin you come
up and they just want you to pick lick
their skin right they don't care about
you you don't get lost in there that's
what happening you know cuz I kind of
sew right through it and like so that's
that's why you guys all came up to me
right and they're prettier to skip right
because they want you to choose their
skit were you the musical guest too as
well no oh you didn't do it must be the
money on I did I did perform but he had
a Philadelphia what's his name really
good darkness from Philadelphia Bon Jovi
Bon Jovi was Bon Jovi Deion Sanders is
hosting Bon Jovi February 18th 1995 the
cast
can you read off the cast that was also
denied yeah go for it was believable I
mean I haven't write in Furman okay they
just call it up on the Iron Age I mean
it was crazy man yeah I mean do you
remember what you skipped that you did
yeah I did a skit with Farley you know
when the kid told Babe Ruth to hit the
homerun right and Farley was in the bed
like he was a kid yeah and he wanted me
he kept one of me okay if you score a
touchdown for me can you do your funky
bands I can you high step on them can
you put your hand on your head
yeah Farley Yan Sanders all right let's
get to what uh what you're also
representing here restore hair calm Leon
I just received my trophy for the
comeback player here for the third year
straight you know this is the best
comeback I'm trying to get Steve Smith
to make a comeback as well but he eat I
think he's thinking about it you're
wondering the thought right but rich I
think you're definitely a candidate both
you guys are candidates now let me let
me seriously walk through this with you
okay okay so what is the actual process
okay so what are they man yeah
grows hair on the sides of his head yes
at a rate we can't explain that's true
right now actually getting my hair cut
plays the trick on us and negates the
top of the head and focuses on the beard
or the back or the chest and we try to
figure out why would you do that Lord I
mean you're a great guy
but you can take the hair at the side of
your head and places there and it grows
and it don't stop growing and I'm back
by your back yes I'm looking good and
I'm getting looks now that I didn't get
like several years ago oh not that I'm
in mind and looks but our ambient looks
I even saw their twofold
through his shades but okay what what if
somebody who has been on television yeah
as a relatively follically challenged
individual for well over a decade yes
well over a deck
but I mean understood Dion I mean
everyday showing up like a daily showing
yeah all of a sudden shows up with hair
no no how weird what that piece is not
lace front rich you're not gonna have
hair tomorrow in just tonight you're not
gonna have that it's gonna be great
jool gradually you're gonna make a
comeback
you can't JJ Watt didn't just jump out
there and become jjy it was good in the
playoffs but he won JJ Watt
so gradually you're gonna make a
comeback to now to this I got a brush
one of the last time you've seen a brush
now I can't recall last time I'm telling
you I think you're worried about what
they're gonna say 100% he's definitely
you need to put him at ease what to go
for that and be you we got women all
over the country they don't worry about
what they're gonna say
so are you do realize though you do
realize that your run of come black
Comeback Player of the Year would be
over yeah if I did this I know I would I
would I would great play wait a minute
ads didn't Urlacher win another licker
right yeah but see we expect Urlacher to
make a comeback you don't expect a
brother to make a comeback where do you
get black hair white dude's been doing
it for years we don't really do that and
we did it restore hair calm Deion
Sanders I Love You Man I love you are
bless you you are one of a kind and I'm
Steve Smith when he gets up here I love
him well he's right there you carry on
our our Honda greenroom area just off to
the side of our set check out right
after Super Bowl 50 for NFL gameday
prime live on NFL Network and restore
hair calm yes Steve Smith when we come
back right here on the Rich Eisen show
oh look at that mother that's you for
your SNL that's it yeah that's the
comeback it look wet but it was dry
could you go high-top fade yes I can't
you could I can't how long would it take
you to go talk about three months I
would love that
that would be great thanks for coming on
Deion Sanders everybody right here on
the rich IV show Steve Smith TV times up
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app